2.2 to go throws up to three
and the Los Angeles Lakers storm back
it's their biggest comeback since
December 6
2002 when they trailed Dallas by 30.
this time they come back
climbing out of a 27-point deficit and
nothing boys a team Spirits more than
this type of win Doris when you're
trying to get into the playing or
playoffs can't say enough about the new
acquisition Jared Vanderbilt and his
impact on the game in a number of
different facets the one-on-one matchup
with Luca the created extra possessions
he goes for a career-high 16 rebounds
this guy was ubiquitous yes the king and
A.D were huge Jared had a big parking
Doris he had